sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation en association avec tv 78 une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg voici une
sélection des meilleurs moments de
l'émission
zone europe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui marque beauté nga
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
eurodéputé belge membre du groupe de la
gauche au parlement européen vous êtes
membre de la commission de l'industrie
et de la recherche et de l'énergie alors
c'est pas la première fois que vous
venez d'en zone europe pour parler de la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par
l'union européenne à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette émission 65% de la
population de l'union est entièrement
vacciner alors est ce qu'on peut dire
déjà que cette mission de vaccination
est réussie
65% c'est bien je dire en soi après il
ya des grandes inégalités au sein de
l'europe je pense au sein de mon pays
aussi mais ce que moi m'inquiète c'est
que on a une situation où mondialement
les inégalités sont absurdes et quand je
dis absurde en fait c'est révoltant et
c'est dangereux donc le british medical
journal qui a un journal médical
prestigieux parle même où s'interroge
sur un crime contre l'humanité pourquoi
parce que dans d'autres pays notamment
des pays à bas revenus il ya souvent que
même pas 3 % de la population qui a été
vaccinée et c'est dramatique parce que
vous savez le virus n'a pas de
frontières ne connaît pas de frontières
plus le virus circule plus il ya des
variants et vous savez qu'en europe on
sera pas en sécurité si demain il ya
peut-être un variant qui échappe aux au
vaccin est donc ce manque disons d'avoir
ou cet échec à voir garantit un accès
universel à ce vaccin c'est aujourd'hui
le problème fondamental est ce que la
stratégie vaccinale c'est finalement la
plus efficace en tout cas la stratégie
vaccinale à très grande échelle en
vaccinant toutes les populations en tout
cas au niveau européen est ce que c'est
la plus efficace et est ce que
finalement on a le droit de critiquer
cette stratégie est d'avoir un autre
point de vue est ce qu'on ait entendu
quand on pense autrement on doit
forcément critiqué cette stratégie je
veux dire moi je vous points déjà les
inégalités et ses inégalités ne sont pas
des fatalités je ne lirai pas quelque
chose qui nous vient du ciel qui nous
tombe dessus abacha il ya des inégalités
non nous savions à la base déjà au début
qu'aucune entreprise n'aurait la
capacité de produire suffisamment de
vaccins pour tout le monde et donc on a
demandé un transfert de technologie une
ouverture du brevet etc ça ne s'est pas
fait l'union européenne est aujourd'hui
au niveau mondial l'opposant plus forts
de cette mesure la donc le fait d
partage des technologies et des brevets
alors bien sûr qu'il faut la critiquer
parce qu'en face de ça on voit big
pharma donc les grandes entreprises
pharmaceutiques qui font des milliards
des dizaines de milliards de bénéfices
et donc il s'agit pas de dire qu' ils
sont en difficulté qu'il faut aider les
entreprises non il faudrait aujourd'hui
en pandémie garante et la santé publique
évidemment ça vient avec toute une série
d'autres mesures qui doivent être prises
par rapport aux soins de santé primaire
par rapport à la prévention par rapport
à l'éducation à la santé etc donc ce
n'est pas que la stratégie vaccinale qui
est importante mais qui a un angle mort
très fort qui est celui d'eads et du
manque de vaccins disons dans les pays
du sud à faible revenu justement les
premiers cas qui ont été déclarés en
europe c'est janvier 2020 le 11 mars de
l'année dernière 11 mars 2020
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
qualifié la situation de pandémie
carrément quels ont été les moments clés
de la gestion de cette crise à quel
moment est ce qu on a commencé à en
parler finalement au parlement européen
et est ce qu'on n'en a pas parlé un peu
tard parce qu'on a commencé à voir les
choses se passaient en chine depuis la
france ou même la belgique on sait au
début déconfinement l'italie le nord de
l'italie était confiné on voyait ça de
très loin alors que finalement c'était
déjà très proches oui je pense que en
belgique encore quelques semaines avant
le confinement on a eu une ministre de
la santé qui a insinué que c'était
finalement une petite grippe 1 on n'a
pas pris au sérieux en tant que
gouvernement ont donc pas nous
particulièrement faire moi pas tellement
parce qu'on n'est pas au gouvernement on
est on est à l'opposition mais les
gouvernements n'ont clairement pas pris
la mesure n'ont pas pris au sérieux ce
qui est en train de se passer on a pensé
ce que richard gross était par manque de
moyens non je pense que c'était par
manque 2 à 2,2 de considération pour le
reste du monde donc ritcher totten qui
est éditeur en chef de rédacteur en chef
de l'enset qui est une revue notre revue
médicale prestigieuse a dit qu'en fait
on a regardé avec mépris les pays
asiatiques où ça se passait on a dit
ouais ça se passe en chine mais bon
toute manière c'est là loin ici c'est
loin d'ici ça restera la sépare des
cultes et donc cohérente on n'a pas pris
au sérieux et quand c'est pour ça que je
dis quand on a une ministre encore
quelques semaines avoir un confinement
généralisée jamais vu
kidioui finalement est ce que c'est bien
pire qu'une grippe c'est évidemment le
symbole ou la preuve qu'on a pas pris
aux seuils comme on n'a pas voulu
prendre au sérieux le besoin d'avoir des
traitements et des vaccins accessibles à
tous partout dans le monde le plus
rapidement possible et on a dit oui on
va investir sur le vaccin on va mettre
le paquet mais on ne va pas demander que
le vaccin soit accessible à tous tout de
suite justement à l'heure où on parle
d'une troisième injection de vasques de
vaccins déjà aux états unis mais même
déjà au sein de l'union on parle de 25 %
de la population mondiale qui est
totalement vacciner majoritairement les
pays riches c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure et sur le continent
africain seuls 5% de la population
serait totalement vacciner alors la
commission européenne est à l'initiative
d'une installation d'une construction du
sinn daawa kz1 sur le continent africain
alors thierry breton commissaire
européen a annoncé plus d'un an un an et
demi pour construire ses usines est-ce
que c'est pas déjà trop tard mais
évidemment d'abord il ya des usines qui
existe qui pourrait fabriquer le vaccin
si on libérait le brevet et s'ils ont
partagé la technologie donc activer la
capacité de production existantes est un
défi est quelque chose qui devrait se
faire mais pour ça il faudrait ouvrir
les technologies ou partager les
technologies et le brevet et sa
l'industrie pharmaceutique l'union
européenne ne veulent pas le faire et
donc est ce qu'ils font ils disent ben
va construire une nouvelle usine qu'on
va financer et qui appartiendra ou dont
le contrôle final sera aux mains des
multinationales européennes a pour ne
pas partir sans importer en europe des
vaccins qu'on va construire en un seul
sait déjà c'est ce qui s'est fait
maintenant avec johnson & johnson en
afrique du sud on vous voyez que en
afrique du sud il ya un manque de
vaccins on à paris on voit que nous
l'union européenne a un deal avec
johnson & johnson pourquoi parce que on
a l'argent de dire ben vendez vos
vaccins à nous chez nous et donc on a
importé on a on apporte des vaccins de
johnson & johnson en europe
en fait en niant ainsi le droit à
l'accès au vaccin aux sud-africains et
donc ça se fait c'est hyper cynique
parce que ce qui se passe c'est pas
c'est pas une question de est ce que les
européens au plus haut - droits que les
appliquer en vaccins la question c'est
est ce que on a droit à la santé ou est
ce qu'on préfère les profits des
multinationales la contradiction elle
est là et donc tant qu'on ne bouge pas
sur cette position dit non le profit
des big pharmas et sacro-saint mais on
n'y arrivera pas il ya des gens qui vont
continuer de mourir est ce que en
entendant emmanuel macron au début de
cette crise d'hier nous sommes en guerre
finalement c'est pas un peu
contradictoire avec le fait de ne pas
libérer
les façons de faire les vaccins de ne
pas libérer ça pour les africains même
le monde entier et bien sûr mais je
voulais quand même rappeler que même au
sol avant de relayer une président de la
commission européenne a dit en avril
2020 donc il ya plus d'un an que le
vaccin devrait être un bien commun
universel
après elle a évidemment fait marcher
mais monsieur macron aussi je m'accroche
à dix les brevets on n'y touche pas puis
il a dit après que joe biden président
américain a dit oui moi je suis en
faveur d'une levée des brevets monsieur
macron à tout d'un coup dit ah oui mais
moi aussi bien entendu et puis ensuite
il a encore changé de position quand il
s'agit de négocier vraiment donc vous
voyez bien que les intérêts sont là mais
sous la pression du public sous la
pression populaire parfois ils doivent
ils doivent céder un peu ils doivent
bouger un peu et donc moi je compte
beaucoup sur cette pression populaire
pour faire changer le rapport de force
vous parlez de pression populaire depuis
le 1er juillet dernier un pass sanitaire
européen appelé certificat covin
numérique de l'union européenne est
entrée en vigueur dans l'ensemble des
pays membres mais son utilisation fait
débat dans les divers pays à lhassa a
été lancée par le danemark 1 dès le mois
d'avril ce mouvement est élargie suivi
avant d'être harmonisées au niveau
européen mais l'utilisation diffèrent
d'un pays à un autre on en discutait
juste avant c'est plutôt très stricte en
france ou encore en italie c'est un peu
plus souple en belgique ou encore en
roumanie ou sa simple ihsane ça ne
s'applique qu'à l'intérieur ou à des à
des rassemblements de plus de 1000 1500
personnes est-ce que vous pensez que
tout d'abord c'est une solution pour
réduire la transmission du virus et est
ce que vous comprenez la population qui
dit que ça ça brade les libertés
individuelles mais il ya évidemment
je trouve d'abord avoir effectivement
vous dites dans différents pays
européens ça se passe de manière
complètement différente donc il ya des
pays qui sont extrêmement strictes je
pense que la france est à peu près le
pays où c'est le plus strict ou même
pour s'asseoir en terrasse on a besoin
de montrer le pass il y en a il ya des
pays qui demandent juste le le passe à
l'entrée du pays donc le pass européens
d'ailleurs pas pas autre chose donc
voilà déjà là on voit qu'il ya une
gestion différenciée comme on l'a vu
tout au long de cette crise jeudi a
jamais eu au niveau européen vraiment
une lunette compter un accord là dessus
par rapport à l'obligation du pass mais
je veux quand même dire que l'état est
en train de renoncer à certaines
responsabilités c'est-à-dire la
responsabilité de convaincre d'organiser
dans dans certains quartiers ou dans
auprès de la population
kiki qui hésitent qui doute et c'est
d'organiser des campagnes d'organiser dû
convaincre vraiment pour parce que la
base de toute campagne de santé publique
doit être l'adhésion mais cette adhésion
requiert un travail des autorités et
requiert un travail d'un système de
soins de santé les soins de santé
primaires etc moi je veux pas peut-être
pas faire confiance à big pharma une
grosse multinationale mais à mon médecin
je veux faire confiance insistons
là-dessus rentrons dans le dialogue
convainquons et c'est hélas l'état et
les différents états malheureusement en
europe refuse rechignent à le faire et
alors et choisissent l'option plus
facile dévoila soit l'obligation
vaccinale mais qui sont des obligations
vaccinales cacher on peut pas en préface
le mans tient en partie on pourrait dire
ça mais le dire le débat reste le même
que ça soit sur ce game place
techniquement on pourrait parce qu'en
france c'est comme ça mais dans d'autres
pays c'est différent donc la question se
pose vraiment différemment mais la
question est ce que votre système de
soin est ce que vous voulez investir
dans votre système de santé créer
l'adhésion ont créé le pressing comme on
dit aussi un donc le suivi des gens est
ce que voulait réagir soul est sur la
balle et c'est là où est ce que vous dit
non je fais là la solution facile et
match comprend l'om est sain
certainement a dit donc l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui a des risques
effectivement par rapport aux libertés
d'attaché incertain comment dire
certains droits un certain statut de
santé et donc il faut certainement
être attentif à cela et moi je veux
insister sur le rôle que devrait jouer
l'état et s'il ya bien une chose qu'on
doit prendre de cette crise c'est que
nous avons besoin d'un système de santé
fort c'est-à-dire de première ligne mais
en général aussi unifier fort et alors
on devrait investir la dent dans nos
services publics pour dire la plus
jamais ce genre de pandémie mais ça je
ne vois pas ni l'état français ni en
belgique 7 7 pouces et deux européens et
certainement pas au niveau européen mais
je m'attends à ce que la commission
européenne ne demande plus jamais un
pays de couper dans ses soins de santé
mais ce qu'elle a fait pendant dix ans
63 x et ben je m'attends aujourd'hui à
ce que la commission européenne aux plus
jamais le faire mais est ce que
finalement le parlement et l'union
européenne n'est pas une trop grosse
machine pour avancer face à une crise
qui avancent très rapidement un virus
qui mute très rapidement mais ça dépend
ce que ce que vous voulez je veux dire
c'est pas le parlement européen qui va
gérer la crise
c'est au niveau européen qui ont à gérer
justement ces négociations avec les big
pharmas absolument et je pense que vous
savez si le but des négociations avait
été on veut acheter ce vaccin au
meilleur prix aux meilleures conditions
dans toute la transparence et c'est à la
soirée était une bonne chose parce qu'on
aurait été 27 pays face au big pharma
pour s'imposer mais le but n'a pas été
ça le but a été de dire on va vous
garantir vos profits en échange on veut
une petite priorité par rapport à vaccin
ça c'est pas du tout ce à quoi devait
servir cette coopération européenne
est-ce que c'est l'échelle moi je
constate que tous les pays ont suivi ces
négociations tous les pays la france
était présente la belgique étaient
présentes l'italie l'allemagne et c'est
donc aucun pays peut dire que c'est
c'est uniquement la faute à la
commission européenne - je critique
fortement la gestion de la commission
européenne qui est celle du profit
d'abord plutôt que celle de la santé
d'abord mais les états les gouvernements
l'ont suivi ont contrôlé et donc c'est
la même logique qui domine au niveau
national en france ou en belgique ou
ailleurs et à la commission européenne
très bien merci beaucoup marketing à
d'avoir été mon invité dans une europe
je rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputé
belge membre du groupe de la gauche au
parlement européen et membre de la
commission de l'industrie de la
recherche et de l'énergie
sonos robe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui stéphane bijoux
eurodéputés membres du groupe renault
europe et président de la délégation à
la commission parlementaire cariforum
-bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
l'auteur du rapport intitulé vers un
renforcement du partenariat avec les
régions ultra périphériques de l'union
alors avant d'entrer dans le vif du
sujet je rappelle que vous êtes né à
saint denis à la réunion et je voudrais
savoir comment on a le sentiment d'être
européen quand on est si éloignées du
vieux continent alors pour être éloigné
ça c'est sûr qu'on est éloigné 9000
kilomètres de bruxelles de strasbourg
sur cette île de la réunion je vais vous
dire moi j'ai grandi sur un territoire
extraordinaire où le dimanche matin je
pouvais me lever en entendant les
pétards du jour de l'an chinois
le fond de l'église catholique à la
messe à 10 heures des tambours tamouls
l'après midi et le soir l'appel à la
mosquée tout ça dans la même journée et
je vais vous dire cette diversité cette
capacité de vivre ensemble finalement
fait qu'il y a un lien naturel entre ce
que nous sommes profondément et l'adn de
l'europe et ce slogan cette devise
européenne unie dans la diversité
alors je peux vous dire que quand on est
sur une île au milieu de l'océan indien
entre madagascar et l'île maurice et que
vous êtes ce que vous êtes fort de cet
héritage du métissage et que vous avez
la possibilité à la fois d'être créole
réunionnais français et européens je
réponds à votre question en disant que
ce qui prédomine c'est de façon légitime
un sentiment de grande fierté très bien
alors on va s'intéresser à ces régions
ultrapériphériques il faut savoir elles
sont rattachées à trois états membres
l'espagne pour les canaries le portugal
pour les açores et madère et bien sûr la
france pour la réunion vous le disais
vous disiez mais aussi mayotte la
guadeloupe la martinique et saint martin
ça représente plus de 4,8 millions
d'habitants de quelle manière l'union
européenne et l'europe apporte son aide
à ces territoires ultramarins au
quotidien de quelle manière est elle
présentée est ce que sur place on voit
une présence de l'europe au quotidien
alors on partage d'abord
citoyenneté européenne et on partage
cette volonté de construire ensemble
chacun de nos territoires et on est dans
le cadre d'un partenariat aux finalement
il faut qu'on soit gagnant-gagnant ça
permet des territoires d'outre-mer
permettent à l'europe c'est 5 millions
de personnes dont vous parliez
exactement répartis sur trois océans
permettent effectivement à l'europe de
rayonner à l'international et en même
temps l'europe mise sur nos territoires
en investissant 13 milliards d'euros
pour les fonds de cohésion pour nos
pêcheurs pour nos agriculteurs pour
construire des lycées pour financer des
programmes de formation pour notre
jeunesse ce sont des choses extrêmement
fondamental et bien évidemment ce qui
est important c'est cet investissement
qui est fait sur l'environnement sur
l'écologie puisque la nature même de nos
territoires qui sont majoritairement des
îles sauf la guyane mais qui est sur le
continent amazonien avec cette forêt
amazonienne et bien les investissements
de l'europe pour l'écologie à un moment
où on investit dans le green deal sont
des choses fondamentales alors en
préambule de votre rapport je le disais
tout à l'heure vous soulignez plusieurs
points ce soit en terme de biodiversité
de dimension marine de maritime de
risque de pollution le taux d'abandon
scolaire vous parliez de construire des
lycées
est ce que ces régions qui font une
richesse pour l'europe sont aussi à
surveiller pour pas qu'il y ait un
sentiment finalement d'appartenance
uniquement à son territoire ultramarin
alors il ya d'abord une réalité qui est
celle de l'espace qui est le nôtre et
les régions ultra périphériques de
l'europe on apporte une surface maritime
qui permet à l'europe d'être la deuxième
puissance maritime mondiale 25 millions
de kilomètres carrés imaginer c'est ou
plus grand comme deux fois la superficie
de la de la russie c'est énorme et ça
pose les choses d'abord en termes de
responsabilité une responsabilité qui
est la nôtre vis-à-vis de la
biodiversité les outre-mer a pris 80 %
de la biodiversité européenne et quand
on sait que
l'iucn tire les experts tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé en disant attention on
est en train de perdre déjà un tiers de
nos plans de nos animaux de nos végétaux
il y à une urgence à agir et agir vite
sur chacun de ces territoires pour ce
qui est de la cohésion et de ce pari sur
la jeunesse ce qui nous caractérise
outre mer ce sont ces le potentiel de
nos jeunes à mayotte par exemple une
personne sur deux a moins de 18 ans ce
n'est pas du tout le cas sur le vieux
continent mais exactement et quand vous
avez cette réalité là vous avez d'abord
une responsabilité qui est celle de
trouver des solutions pour ouvrir
l'horizon de nos jeunes mois chez moi
l'île de la réunion quand je croise des
jeunes puisque je suis systématiquement
sur le terrain à la rencontre et à
l'écouté de no fun il m'a dit mais
monsieur le député en créole août
l'horizon les cas c'est notre horizon
est cassé et quand vous êtes face à des
jeunes qui n'ont pas de perspective est
bien votre responsabilité c'est de
construire des solutions et l'europe est
un partenaire efficace aux côtés de la
volonté du gouvernement français de
construire des solutions pour les autres
vous parliez de changement qui est de
changement climatique est-ce que vous
pensez que le tourisme durable parce que
le tourisme c'est finalement un des
grands pans de l'économie de ce
territoire est ce que le tourisme
durable doit être une priorité pour ces
régions alors c'est plus qu'une priorité
je vais vous dire il y a une légitimité
à miser sur les outre mer pour
construire moi un tourisme durable moi
je réclame ici au parlement européen la
création d'un label tourisme durable
élire soir j'ai dit au commissaire
thierry breton mais miser sur nous misez
sur les outre mer pourquoi parce que
comme nous sommes en première ligne du
dérèglement climatique
nous construisons des solutions pour
effectivement avoir un autre mode de
fonctionnement un nouveau modèle de
développement basé sur cette
réconciliation nécessaire entre
l'économie et l'écologie et le tourisme
est un périmètre sur lequel on peut
construire des solutions durables en
polynésie française par exemple on est
capable aujourd'hui de climatisé des
hôtels en allant puiser l'eau froide au
fond des océans sans produire du gaz
néfastes pour l'environnement on est
capable aujourd'hui dans nos territoires
de construire des offres où on peut
trouver cette réconciliation cette
capacité à vivre en harmonie avec la
nature parce que nous sommes ce que nous
sommes et parce que nous donnons les
moyens avec l'europe avec le
gouvernement de créer des solutions
concrètes alors il ya l'inquiétude de
ses de ces régions c'est aussi et
qu'elles font souvent face à des flux
migratoires importants beaucoup s'en
vont justement vers la france
métropolitaine
une situation qui inquiète parfois les
autorités locales comment est-ce qu'on
peut les soutenir
et quelle solution on peut préconiser
pour gérer aussi parfois l'arrivée de
migrants il faut d'abord accorder
beaucoup d'importance à ce que
ressentent nos concitoyens sur cette
question des migrations je veux d'abord
dire que ce que nous sommes
fondamentalement dans les outre mer nous
sommes les héritiers des migrations dans
chacune de nos régions nous sommes métis
et le sang qui coule dans nos veines
fait que nous sommes les héritiers d'une
tradition de métissage de rencontres de
l'immigration c'est quelque chose de
fondamental qui fait que sur nos
territoires nous devons avoir une
approche humaine de ces questions de
migration il y à une réalité
effectivement qu'il faut regarder en
face trouver la solution demande du
courage et le premier courage c'est de
faire le bon diagnostic et de regarder
les choses en face aujourd'hui à mayotte
par exemple à la maternité de mamoudzou
et bien cet enfant sur dix qui naissent
naissent d'une mère en situation
irrégulière qui est arrivé de l'état
voisin des comores il faut qu'on trouve
des solutions pour régler ces situations
le gouvernement avec l'aide de l'europe
mise sur des moyens supplémentaires de
surveillance de nos zones pour
effectivement
trouver les solutions les bonnes
solutions parce que je vais vous dire
face à cette situation l'extrême droite
propose
juste d'agiter les peurs mais à aucun
moment ne propose deux solutions on va
quand même pas construire des murs sur
nos récifs pour régler ces réguler les
migrations la solution ne passe pas par
là elle passe aussi je le revendique par
une capacité de dialogue avec les pays
d'où viennent ces migrants qui viennent
sur nos territoires d'ailleurs la
réalité c'est qu'ils viennent de pays
différents quand on est à mayotte la
migration elle vient essentiellement des
comores quand on est en guyane le flux
arrive de haïti il faut qu'on soit en
capacité avec l'union européenne de
parler de négocier de construire des
solutions avec les pays d'origine de ces
migrants et il faut que sur notre sol en
soit en capacité d'accueillir ceux qui
ont besoin d'être parce que c'est aussi
ça la réalité il y à des hommes des
femmes des enfants qui ont besoin d aide
et c'est l'honneur de la france
l'honneur de l'europe de trouver les
bonnes solutions avant de se quitter un
moment sur la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe une plateforme qui permet de
s'exprimer future rue pour un repas
point e u pour vous à quoi ressemblerait
l'europe idéal on sait que l'europe est
plein de défauts de qualité aussi qu'est
ce que vous voudriez peut-être changé
alors
je ne sais pas s'il existe quelque chose
de parfait dans dans dans ce monde mais
pour autant il faut avoir un idéal il
faut avoir des idées aux alors l'europe
idéal pour moi ça serait l'europe qui
s'est d'abord l'europe qu'on essaye de
construire pour laquelle on se mobilise
avec mon groupe politique sous
l'impulsion du président de la
république française pour que cette
europe elles permettent à chaque
citoyenne à chaque citoyen à chaque
européen peu importe le territoire
d'europe où il vit y compris dans les
outre-mers les plus éloignés permettre à
chacune et à chacun d'être debout d'être
debout et non pas à 6 pi rage nous un
face à des situations internationales
qui se tendent face à des défis mondiaux
qui sont extrêmement puissants que ce
soit le défi climatique que ce soit le
défi social économique culturel
l'émigration vianney l'interné on l'a vu
et d'être mais bien sûr de la santé et
d'être 2 bout face à ces défis et je
crois en la capacité collective qui est
la nôtre parce que je crois en
l'intelligence collective nous avons la
possibilité de construire les solutions
pour affronter ensemble ces grands défis
la conférence pour l'avenir de l'europe
est un moment extrêmement important et
d'ailleurs ce chemin des couteaux des
citoyennes et des citoyens passent par
les outre-mers parce que quand on a
lancé les conférences régionales pour
l'avenir de l'europe en même temps on
réfléchissait à lille ou à bordeaux à
l'île de la réunion chez moi le ministre
de l' europe les moins bonne est venu
pour donner le coup d'envoi de cette
impulsion pour que nous construisions
ensemble cette europe forte solidaire
dont nous avons besoin merci beaucoup
stéphane bijoux d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
membres du groupe renault europe
président de la délégation la commission
parlementaire kari kari forum e et je
rappelle à l'adresse de la plate forme
future eu une pointe europa.eu si vous
souhaitez donner votre avis sur l'avenir
de
soul rock
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine très bonne soirée
sonne robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france